what we have
mentioned from the words of ibn al-qaeda
to allah regarding the decree of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and as a matter of fact
he has an entire book dedicated to the
issue of decree
it's called shifa and this book
it's a very dense book it's a very well
written book
but complex nonetheless
given the subject matter and that is
regarding
the decree of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
regarding the stages and levels of the
decree the qadhar of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
of allah subhanahu wa
and this issue
of al-qaeda is as we've mentioned before
very complicated
issue it's not an issue that
is to be taken lightly and it's not an
issue that is to be taken for granted
that a person just assume that he
understands
what decree is and assume that he or she
knows
what the decree of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala entails
it is one of the pillars of faith
and oftentimes these things which are
common knowledge
to muslims or are supposed to be common
knowledge to muslims
well that knowledge is not so common a
lot of times
there are a lot of inconsistencies with
regards to the muslim belief
and this has a lot to do with the
collapse of the muslim
empire many years ago
and it has a lot to do with the laxness
in with regards to who
is permitted to speak and who is
permitted
to teach the religion of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
it's also connected very deeply to the
disconnect between the different and
various muslim
countries
the muslim empire is one
nation allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala had
decreed it to be this way
that this nation of yours shall be one
nation
and i am your lord so worship me
and the issue that occurred
is that when the muslim empire
no longer had a central
no longer had a center to it
and we were given these countries
that everybody is from not that we don't
have our identities before
but these countries and these borders
that were given to us by foreign nations
and people that are not muslim these
things created in our minds
differences between one another that do
not exist
differences that should not exist
between muslims
and so the jordanian views the
palestinian as different than himself
the palestinian views himself different
than the syrian
who views himself different than the
lebanese who views himself different
than the egyptian
who views himself different than the
libyan etc etc
these boundaries were not
given to us by allah and his messengers
these are things that were given to us
by foreign nations
by people that did not have our best
interest at heart
and so as time went on and it went and
it became
this is my land and this is your land
this is my passport and this is your
passport
and this is my nationality and this is
your nationality
this is my country and this is your
country
the muslim mind began to scatter
and it began to change and so in the
last 200 years we've seen a lot of this
happen
a lot and it runs much deeper than we
can think and we can imagine
and one of the main things that this has
done
is that each country has its own
scholars now
and each country has its own beliefs
and each country has its own thoughts
and ideas
and these thoughts and ideas and
countries are not usually run
by the scholars true scholars
they are usually run by the government
of that particular country and the
government of that particular country
is not always a government that
is of the people and for the people
it's usually quite the opposite
and so it's important for us to
understand these differences
to understand why it is that we have
differed so much as muslims
as muslims we are all one we have our
our
our identities as human beings
but as muslims we are all the same there
is no one higher than anyone else
we don't have a pope we don't have a
a religious hierarchy where they decree
things and it goes downward it doesn't
work that
as muslims every muslim
is as good as his
worship is to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
as muslims there is total equality
in that sense there is a difference
between a leader
and a follower there's a difference
between a scholar and a layman
there's a difference between someone
older and younger
there's a difference between a criminal
and a law abiding person
we're not speaking about blind
absolute equality we're speaking about
equality in the spiritual sense
spiritual equality spiritually we are
all the same there's no difference
between us
and as muslims there's no difference
and this is what something hajj is
supposed to capture
this is something salah is
it captures that we all pray to the same
direction
we all pray the same prayer we all go
to the same place to make hajj etc
now what does this have to do with the
decree of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
well what it has a lot to do with it
is that when we come to these classes
for instance
or those of us who listen online
the avid more astute listeners online
they will learn a lot of new things
they'll learn things and they'll say
well i've never heard of that
i've and that's that's kind of the point
isn't it
i mean if every time you came here you
heard something you already knew
then you're not really learning anything
the position of a teacher is to teach
is to remind what you have forgotten to
explain what you already have what you
have misunderstood
and to teach you new information that
you did not know prior
and so when it comes to the
five pillars of islam
right the shahada of
muhammad rasool allah the
establishment of prayer the giving zakah
fasting ramadan
when it comes to these things we all
agree that these are the five pillars of
islam
when it comes to the the pillars of iman
al-imanu billah and his angels
and his books revelations and his
prophets and messengers and the day of
resurrection and the decree
we all agree that there are six pillars
of amen
but the problem is is that when we start
to discuss the details of these things
we start to differ with one another on
things that
are not open to discussion they're not
open to debate
there are issues that the scholars of
islam have differed on
historically even the companions
may have differed on minutia of prayer
or minutia of fasting or minutia of
zakah
but they have never differed on what la
[Arabic recitation]
and they've never differed on what
implicates
they've never differed on the
implications of muhammad rasulullah
implications of the names and attributes
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
they've never differentiate different
they've never had
differences with regards to
who the angels are or
with regards to what the revelations of
allah subhanahu ta'ala are
or the nature of those revelations or
what those revelations revolve around
and one of these things is the issue of
the issue of decree the issue of
al-qaeda
this is something that has been highly
debated
and it's been highly debated because as
even allah said the
origin of every innovation is someone
who is not
qualified speaking about something they
are unqualified to speak about
that is where every innovation comes
from
us
this is the origin of all ignorance and
all
innovation and so
yes it happened in the time of the
companions
that a group of people began to emerge
and come up with very
very fantastic ideas when i say
fantastic
i mean it in the negative sense with
regards to the decree of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and things got so bad that some
groups even believe that allah did not
even know
that we exist this is this is true
islam is
[Silence]
you know people had gone so far
with this slippery slope and when we
speak about slippery slope
slippery slope is a term that is used in
debate
which means if this is the case then
this must be the case
and if this is the case then this must
be the case
and you continue down that slippery
slope until you
end up in a place that is absolutely
incorrect
absolutely wrong why because the premise
is wrong in the first place
and so what does that ancient difference
have to do
with the separation of the muslim ummah
today
what do those two things have to do with
each other
the things that they have to do with
each other is that when there was a
centralized muslim
empire and there was a khalifa
and there was regulations
if a person wishes to be a scholar there
is an apprenticeship
in order to become a scholar you have to
go through certain
training you have to be known as a
scholar you have to be qualified as a
scholar
right when that
centralized leadership was gone
everybody now had free reign to do
whatever they wanted to do
and to say whatever they wanted to say
and so essentially what ended up
happening is
all of the old garbage the things that
the scholars of islam
put into the garbage dump
and said these ideas are obviously not
of ours
these are islam
and islam now that there are no
there is no regulation there is no
centralized islamic empire
there is no regulations of
who can say what there are no
ramifications there are no
consequences anybody can show up now
especially in our time i mean think
about it anybody can put on a
nice suit and jacket and put on a
pen and a glasses and a fancy big hat
and sit down and speak very nice and
everybody here will become the next
islam of our instagram era
this is the time that we live in
unfortunately
right it's very very easy for imposters
now to
make their way into the minds and hearts
of the people
and so what ended up happening is those
things which were in the garbage dump
before
they started to pull out that garbage
and put it back into
people's hearts and so now we differ
[Silence]
it's a free-for-all anybody can say
anything now
and so when we talk about the issue of
decree
we are speaking about decree as
understood by the prophet muhammad
we are not speaking about decree as a as
understood by such and such scholar or
such and such individual
this is not what we are speaking about
when we speak about the issue of decree
the book of ibm allah
when we are speaking about these things
and in that book
he is speaking about decree al-qaeda
al-qaeda he's speaking about it
in the way that the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and his
companions
understood it and that's important for
us to understand
that we have to understand the religion
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
not just according to the quran and
sunnah
but we have to understand the quran and
sunnah in the way that the companions
understood it because to merely
i mean the way that the quran is
is is spoken by allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala the way that the sunnah is
if you are clever enough you can find
whatever you want in the
quran you can make it say whatever you
want it to say
based on what you choose right
issue is not to just understand the
quran
it's not just to read it and use it as
evidence it's not just to understand the
sunnah
it's to understand the quran and sunnah
in the proper way what is the proper way
the proper way is the way that the
companions
understood it because they were the ones
who were
under the thumb of the prophet salallahu
he was the one watching them he was the
one who raised them
he was the one who reared them and
cultivated them he taught them himself
and allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
made their belief the measuring and the
yardstick
of proper belief he says
[Silence]
he said in surat al-baqarah
if they the non-muslims believe in what
you
all have believed when this verse was
revealed allah was speaking to the
companions he was saying what you
all have believed meaning you the
companions you the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
was the first chapter of the quran to be
revealed
in medina correct and so we're speaking
about the muhajireen and the ansar
he said so if they believe
those who are not muslim in what you
all have believed then indeed they have
become guided
what's the opposite meaning of that if
we were to flip that into a negating
statement
if they do not believe in what you all
have believed
then they have become disc misguided
right so
when we say belief in allah we're
speaking about belief in allah
in the way that allah intended
when we're speaking about belief in the
messenger of allah we're speaking about
belief in the messenger of allah
in the way that he has intended
to
[Silence]
this statement this statement should be
at the core at the heart of every muslim
this is
this is how we are to look at the quran
in sunnah
he said i have believed in allah
and what has come to me and what has
come to us from allah
in the way that allah intended
and i have believed in the messenger of
allah
and all that has come to us from the
messenger of allah
in the way that the messenger of allah
intended
and if we had the time and if this
weren't our topic
we could bring dozens of verses of the
quran
that could show you how people have
understood the quran
understood the sunnah but understood it
in a way that allah did not intend
right i'll give one very
very quick example of this
one example of this is
that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
a certain ruling for example
let's say the cutting of the hand of the
thief
right in the arabic language is all the
way from here to the
shoulder so where are we supposed to
make this cut at
we don't know unless we look at the sun
now we don't know unless we look at how
the companions did it
allah
there was a group that came after
who disregarded the sunnah
disregarded what the companions used to
do and say and understand
and they used to cut off a person's hand
all the way from his
from his armpit all the way from the
shoulder
they would cut off his hand cut off his
entire arm
why because of a discrepancy in the
arabic language
foreign
[Silence]
and the topic is very lengthy
mentions to us almost as a preface
at the beginning of his book zad
al-ma'ad which we are reading
he says that the scholars of islam
are the stars
the scholars of islam
are the stars in the sky
he said if the kaaba is right in front
of you
you don't need to look to the stars to
see
where the kaaba is because it's right
there
you can see it it's clear correct
for example when allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says
and your lord is one right
we don't need a scholar to come and tell
us yes
allah is one the kaaba is there
we see it we don't need the stars to
tell us that
he said but if you are cannot see the
kaaba
if you cannot see where it is and have
no idea which direction it
is you look to the stars and they will
guide you to the direction of the qibla
he said allah
[Silence]
he said the scholars are the stars
when the kaaba is right in front of you
you look right at it and you pray
but if you cannot see the kaaba and you
don't know which direction it is
at that point we need the scholars we
need the stars to
guide us to where it is for those things
and so the issue of as we've mentioned
last week
the issue of qatar and qatar are four
stages
in order for us to understand what
al-qaeda
is you know in order for us to
understand the decree of allah
it is four levels four stages
these four levels four things when they
are put together
in the heart of the believer this person
has properly believed in
the decree of allah so when jibreel
[Silence]
and that you believe in decree
the good of it and the bad of it
what we have to understand here is
these four levels when we put them
together
in the order that we are going to put
them together
this is what he intended when he made
that statement sallallahu alaihi
last week we spoke about the first level
of decree
the first level is
the second thing that we spoke about
last week was
subhanahu
[Silence]
so the first thing is knowledge that
allah always
knew the second is that he documented
and wrote that knowledge
in what is called the preserved tablet
and it's also referred to as
right this is all a reference to the
same thing
the preserved tablet we spoke about
those two things
in great detail last week and the week
before
we're going to finish up the last two
tonight inshallah
ta'ala the third level
subhanahu
he the third thing we're going to
understand tonight
is the will of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
the will of allah
so he knows all that is to be
he wrote all of this down in the
preserved tablet
and thirdly he willed
for what is in that tablet to come to
fruition
he willed what is in that tablet to come
to be
to happen to occur
and that that does not happen
without allah subhanahu wa ta'ala having
decreed it
correct nothing happens without allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
allowing it to happen
nothing can occur without allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
not only allowing it but willing it to
occur
he is the only he is the only
creator and he is the only one
whose will is absolute
meaning
when allah decrees that something will
occur
it will occur no matter what
and this is the meaning of the statement
of the prophet salallahu
[Silence]
this is what we call freak accidents
right
that no amount of
preparation and fortitude
can stop what allah has willed happen
and what allah wills occur
it doesn't mean that we don't try to
stop something before it happens
that's not what we're talking about let
me give you an example
right a good example
is a person wears a bulletproof vest
okay they wear this vest
and this vest the idea of the vest is
that if a bullet hits it it will stop
the bullet from penetrating the body
armor is something that the prophets and
messengers brought to humanity
who was the first person to create armor
for battle man
allah
that's a real question for those who are
present
isn't it
right so a person wears this
armor to protect him
but the person gets shot in the exact
perfect place where that
armor was weak and the bullet goes
through
what do we say
there is no amount of preparation and
fortitude
that can stop the will of allah
subhanahu
when allah wills for something to happen
it will happen
regardless of what we do about it
i'll give another example
when we have stairs stairs are scary
things the person could fall down the
stairs they could get very hurt
right so what do we do we put all kinds
of
sandpaper tape on it and things that
when you step on it it'll grab your foot
so that you don't fall and you can hold
your
footing right does that mean that
nobody ever is going to ever fall on
stairs
no you're going to fall people will fall
no matter what you do
even if all of the ummah got together
and held this person
and walked him down the stairs they're
going to fall because allah decreed it
surprised
right this is sometimes what we refer to
in english as freak accidents
the things lined up just perfectly
for this thing to happen why because
allah willed for it to happen
and that is one of the things that sets
us different
sets us aside from the muslims
and the non-muslims the people of belief
in allah and the people who do not
believe in allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
as he has intended in his qadah
there is a difference why
because how do we know
the will of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
this is the question for me to pick up
this cup right now how did we know that
allah willed for this to happen right
how did we know that allah willed that
we know that allah will that because i
did it and it happened
but before it happened did we know that
it was allah's will or not
we didn't know
that allah
[Silence]
this is the issue that a lot of people
misunderstand
that we'd to get to the crux of
that we'd to understand tonight
and that is that when we speak about the
will of allah
the will of allah will come to pass
there is no way that it can be stopped
there is nothing that can stop the will
of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
if a person is meant to die he will die
if a person is meant to live he will
live
if a person is meant to feel pain
he will feel pain this is the decree of
allah
but here's the catch and here's where
people get confused
and that is that we do not know what the
will of allah
is until after it happens
before that we don't know that it's the
will of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
right and i gave an example of that just
now
for me to move this microphone right
here we all agree
that that was the will of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
but before i did it did we know that it
was the it was the will of allah we
didn't know
we only knew it was the will of allah
after
it happened right
and so we have an attitude towards
bad things that occur and good things
for that matter
we have a different attitude before they
happen
as opposed to after they happen
this is a lesson that so many of us need
to learn
and it's not a lesson that we need to
learn just you know lip service just
you know i understand it i'm i can speak
fancy and
no we need to really believe it
in the depths of our hearts we have to
believe this lesson
that before something happens we don't
know if it's the decree of allah
so we try our best to make it what
we want it to be but
after it happens that is final it is the
decree of allah
we never go back and say
if i had been there if i had done if i
had only said
if i had only been that
is not something which is up to us
this is something that is up to allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
we understand that concept if we
understand that concept
we will understand a few narrations that
i will mention to you now
is
[Silence]
in the narration of collected by lima
muslim
he said
the strong believer
is more beloved and closer and better
to allah than the weak one
yet there is good in both there is good
in all of them
he says
seek aid in allah and do not ever give
up
in doing the things that you know that
you should be doing
and doing the right thing don't ever
give up
and seek aid in allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala in that
he says
and if in that process you are afflicted
with something that does not go the way
that you planned
or something that is bad do not say to
yourself
if only i had done such and such
the outcome would have been different
because
if only in this context
opens the door
and we will end with this narration
tonight inshaallah
he says to ibn abbas
young boy i am going to teach you
some very wise words
he says
he says young boy
be aware of allah
and allah will be aware of you
ta'amura
get to know allah in your times of ease
and in your times of hardship he will be
there for you and you will find him
there
he says
and know that whatever has missed you
was never meant to hit you
and whatever had hit you or afflicted
you was
never meant to miss you it could have
never been any other way
keep this in mind in your life
he says
[Silence]
and know that if all of the creation
were to collaborate to benefit you with
something
they could never benefit you with
anything
that allah has not already written for
you
so it has come to you from allah
and know that if all of the creation
were to collaborate
in order to harm you with something
they could never do so with and they
could never harm you with
anything that allah has not already
written
to be upon you
he said and no that
the ease of the crisis comes with
the crisis and that
victory comes with patience
and that with hardship comes ease
this is enough for tonight and next week
inshaallah we will continue
and finish hopefully we will try to
finish
what we have spoken about with regards
to the decree of allah
taken from zed and also taken from
allah
thank you for your listening barack
hello people